I'm Min Jenkinson, and I teach crafters
how to make stickers. I got started 10
years ago. I'd been diagnosed with
breast cancer.
And while going through chemotherapy and
radiation, I still needed something to
take my mind off everything I was going
through. So, a creative project that
came to mind was teaching myself to make
stickers. And so, during chemo, that's
what I did.
Now, little did I know that 10 years on
from that, [music] I've now turned this
into a business where I've taught over
20,000 crafters from all over the world
to make stickers.
>> Hi.
>> Min, what's up? You ready? So, tell me
about the business.
>> I help people make stickers. For the
last 12 months, I made uh 1.1 million
Australian, which roughly works out to
be about 800k. Um so, [music] I've made
multiple seven figures over the past 10
years altogether, but hit my first
seven-figure year, which is very
exciting. So, profit is around the 30 to
35% mark, and my [music]
goal for the next 3 years is to reach 3
million USD [music]
per year.
>> How do you make money?
>> I make money uh with low-ticket digital
products. So, all of my teaching is
online, and my main membership is Secret
Sticker Society. Currently, the rates
are $27
per month or 217 per year. And then,
loads of other low-ticket digital
products that can be interchanged for
upsells. I have really good upsell game,
so that's great.
>> Okay, there's a lot of stuff, though.
So,
how many funnels is this?
>> Over the last 10 years, um I would be
embarrassed to tell you how many funnels
I have.
>> are you running right now?
>> So, right now with the main membership,
with Secret Sticker Society, the main
funnel is a live paid bootcamp that I
launch three times per year.
>> But, the main thing is it's Secret
Sticker Society. You've got a bunch of
upsells in the funnel to upsell to the
greatest degree possible.
>> Yeah.
>> You go to the launch, and then you sell
Secret Sticker Society in the back.
>> That's right.
>> Okay, got
>> Yeah.
>> What are the numbers you got for
acquisition?
Okay. The live paid launch is $10. Is it
The ticket's 10 bucks?
>> That's right.
>> So, there's no free.
>> No free.
>> So, it's paid Okay. Paid challenges.
Cost you $37 to get it.
>> Yes.
>> You have a 22% conversion rate on
>> into the membership.
>> Of people who buy a ticket.
>> That's right.
>> That's huge.
>> Yeah, I'm really happy with that.
>> What's AOV?
>> It would be about 36
dollars.
>> almost breaking even.
>> Some of the events I slightly in the
red, but by the end of the event I'm
always profitable. And then two of the
boot camps that I've run have been
profitable from day one. So, I've been
up.
They're my favorite ones.
>> Okay.
All right. What do you think is stopping
you right now?
>> I feel that if I could get more people
into the challenge, I feel so strong now
that I have that strong conversion of
bringing people in. I know what to do.
It's really quite tried and tested. If I
could get a high volume of people into
the boot camp, I'm I'm safe to convert
them.
>> Yeah.
>> Um so, that has been something that has
definitely held me back. And then as you
know, I I know that I have not reached
the cap in any way of being able to
lower that CPA. So,
I I think that even just making the
switch with the past launch of pushing
the annual membership
doubled the average order value. So,
that made a huge difference. Way bigger
than I thought it would. And then
instantly so,
>> Step one, add the annual. Make that the
only offer available. I want to be
clear. The only offer available is the
annual with the bonuses.
>> Okay. So, annual only at the next
launch.
>> Yes.
>> Someone wise told me to do that. And I
did it and [laughter] it worked. Okay.
Yeah.
>> Yeah, we'll probably do some more stuff
there, too.
>> Yeah, great.
>> Okay. So, why is scaling so important to
you?
Why don't you just make money and just
chill where you're at?
>> Well,
I really want to be able to pay off my
home loan. I'm married. I've got two
kids. Um 10 years ago when I set the
business up, I was diagnosed with breast
cancer. Um, thankfully, 10 years on, all
is really well now, which is great. But,
at the time, which was obviously a very
dark period of my life, I set the
business up really as a creative project
to do something just for me to take my
mind off it. And little did I know that
10 years on, I'd be teaching 20,000 plus
crafters to make stickers. I'm
ex-corporate, so completely different to
what I've done before. Um, but what this
has left me with is a really strong
desire to be able to set my family up
financially. I really want to set up my
family in a way that if I'm no longer
around, they are looked after. I know I
can absolutely still help my mom and
help my family.
And having lost so many friends to
cancer and so many who are moms as well,
it just just become more and more
important to me to appreciate how
my income and how money can really
change our lives. Um,
and I want to know that I've done as
much as possible and I've been able to
support my family
even without me.
I'm here to to be open and to learn. And
I will implement on everything that I'm
told to do. I'm a really good student
verging on being a bit of a teacher's
pet. Like, I will just do anything that
um, you know, that you know more than me
on this. And I constantly tell myself
that I only know what I don't know.
>> more about stickers than I do, that's
for sure.
>> Well, not for long because [laughter]
>> Can you pull the uh, the the number
slide back up real quick? So, you're
making about over 500 ish in profit,
right? So, you're very profitable.
Correct?
>> Mhm.
>> Why don't you spend up to $100
CPA?
>> See, this is part of the reason I'm here
cuz I often finish a launch thinking,
>> I should have spent more.
>> Why didn't I spend more? And then I'll
go into the next launch again with that
same, I'll cap my ad spend at a certain
amount for no good reason.
>> So, what do you What do you cap your CPA
at normally?
>> I don't even Well, I have capped the
CPA, but this the CPA has gone as high
as maybe 50.
I'm not a cautious spender, but for some
reason that's what I've done.
>> here.
>> Yeah.
>> Cool, let's rock. Let's do this.
>> I've known of her. I,
you know, knew that she had an amazing
seven-figure business.
Stickers. Doing stickers. It's so
unique, and so
to me that that was the biggest in terms
of competition.
>> Just so I'm clear on the delivery side,
if you double the amount of customers
you have, does it break anything?
>> No.
>> Okay.
So, this is a pure demand issue, which
is nice. I think I'm going to go I'm
going to kind of break this into
I don't know, offer, and then we'll go
traffic. Cuz I don't think there's
really much else for your specific
business that we need to talk about.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
So, number one, I guess on the traffic
side from the spend, is How much did you
spend last last launch?
>> I I only spent about 16k. The event went
really well. It was not my biggest
event, but it was still profitable. So,
>> Okay.
>> yeah. Happy. Just didn't have enough
time to be able to
>> You just needed more runway.
>> Yeah.
>> So,
when you said you didn't have enough
time to spend more, what do you mean by
that? Cuz like I spent 500,000 a day at
the end of my launch.
>> You said 500,000 a day?
>> Yeah.
>> For ads?
What What What made you
>> This is where my um my own limitation
with Meta ads probably comes into play.
So, what the way that I like to normally
do my launches, which I know is much
earlier than many others, I launch 4
weeks out.
>> That was 4 weeks out?
>> Oh, cool. With a like a smaller spend,
you know, the testing, seeing what
works. And um I didn't have I didn't
feel like I had the runway to be able to
do that. I guess it was a bit of mindset
stuff, too, of like
being way more conservative than I
normally would. But I remember feeling I
wasn't happy enough with CPA
>> Okay.
>> spending.
So,
Okay, so I'm going to I'm going to walk
through spend cadence.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And so, the way that um I do this,
I put about 5% 5 maybe 10% max of my
spend
>> Mhm.
>> goes in that first week.
And the only purpose is to test
creative.
>> Right. Yeah.
>> Then once we have our creative, the next
2 weeks are pretty much flat. Now, we
scale it up obviously.
>> Mhm.
>> But, then we try and spend as much as
possible. Like, I mean, if we could
spend 75% I would. It just It's just
challenging.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Right? Like, call it 60 to 70% is in
this week.
>> Totally.
>> And then we're we're in this call it,
you know, 15% Yeah, maybe 10% here and
then 15% here. And so, even here,
this is where you're probably going to
be at 50% is like literally in the last
3 days, right?
Now, that's the cadence of spending.
Now, from an amount of spending
perspective, we do have a decision which
is like let's obviously be willing to
spend more, all right? But, in order to
do that, I think there's two things we
have to do before we ramp. One is we
have to fix offer. But, I also want to
approach this from a creative
perspective. So, how many pieces of
creative are you making right now for a
launch?
>> This is my weak spot for sure,
creatives. Last launch, I think I
started with a whole test in that first
week with um
two images and two videos.
This time, it'll be a few more. So, I
want you to think in hundreds.
Uh we won't be talking hundreds.
>> We have to.
>> No, I don't think
>> do people make?
>> Oh, thousands.
>> Right. So, let's just think in think in
hundreds, right?
>> Previously, it was not been anywhere
near hundreds.
>> Okay. So, so let's just just to make
this easier for you. Okay, are you
familiar with AI stuff or you like more
versed in it? Okay. So, there's no
reason why you shouldn't have a ton of
static ads cuz these take 2 seconds to
make. So, from a static perspective, um
I would look at a couple different
sources because I want for sure we can
make some and we're going to make a
bunch of them with AI and all that kind
of stuff. But I think if you can
take it from your group, how many
screenshots can I take from the group?
>> Oh, so many.
>> Right? These are all ads, right? And
then you add your little highlights to
them.
To your to the people in your group.
>> Mhm.
>> Do you have the people who post videos
inside the group of them like making
their first, okay?
>> No.
>> So no one does?
>> No video UGC.
>> Interesting.
>> Yeah.
>> You want to incentivize people to?
>> Tried before and um I don't know whether
it's the demographic or perhaps it
didn't set them up for success.
>> Okay.
>> Might probably both.
>> Okay. Well, they know how to use a
phone.
>> For sure. Yeah, yeah.
>> Right. So I would I would have a super
secret sticker
set.
SSSS set. Right? Which they can unlock
if they show themselves making a
sticker.
>> Right. Okay, I love that. Yeah, I love
it.
>> That's it. And then I would use that as
my activation for everyone.
>> Yeah.
>> Which is that everyone in your first 7
days I need you to make a sticker.
>> I really like that cuz that's great for
onboarding, too.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah, so quick win.
>> So it's a quick win, but then every
single customer makes you an ad.
Then around and around we go. And so if
you have 200 customers for every launch
on the low side, that's 200 ads.
>> I wish I thought of that.
>> Well, there you go. We're here. And then
do people post images of the stickers
they make?
>> Oh, yeah. There's no stopping them.
>> Right. So then sticker images I think
you'll be surprised that some of these
will will actually turn into like what
kind of sticker like that's the weirdest
sticker I've ever seen. It's like great.
And then it um so I think sticker ads
will lend themselves really well. So we
have our static ads, we have videos.
Um this will get more people to do it.
We can put that in the activation
sequence in the first 7 days. Great.
Love that. What touchpoints do you have
with your customers?
>> The only live delivery that I do where I
am connected in is during these
bootcamps cuz they're
the classes are pre-recorded, but I go
live every day. And I also invite my
>> All lives, I just want you to clip
because you're already doing it.
>> I've got so many previous ones.
>> Yeah. So just clip them and these can
both go as organic
>> Mhm.
>> and paid.
>> Like
>> Q&A or
>> Just just the small exactly. Quick tips,
exactly. And then for you specifically,
so all of this is just stuff that's
happening that we should be capture.
>> Yeah.
>> But you specifically I would say like I
would want you to make
20 ads times four.
>> Yeah.
>> So like 80 ads
that are just you, but I want the four
to be different backgrounds and
settings. So take your highest
converting ads of all time
>> Mhm.
>> over the last how many campaigns you've
done, put all 20 in here.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you one of each of them in four
different settings, different t-shirt,
different background, different
whatever.
>> Right.
>> And that'll get you your kind of 80. So
it's like if we're going from four ads
to 80 ads and that's just from this and
we still have all of these.
The last thing that I would I would like
to think about before you're you've um
I know you have my
my ads playbook, correct?
>> I believe
>> playbook, yes, exactly. So on the levels
of awareness piece
>> The five levels of awareness is a
framework by Eugene Schwartz where every
person in the market falls into five
categories. So your advertising should
speak to them differently. He contends
that audiences go from the bottom, which
is the warmest and smallest group, to
the top, which is the coldest and
largest. [music] For Mim's business, in
order to continue to scale her ads, she
needs to target more pain or problem
aware audiences rather than product or
offer aware audiences.
>> To make sure that you don't get caught
in like when you scale it up, you scale
up your ads, they don't perform.
>> Yeah.
>> Like they'll stop performing as well.
Now there's always going to be some rise
up because it goes up when you spend
more, that's normal. But if all of a
sudden it triples or something like
that, typically it's because you have
ads that are only really targeted at a
very specific audience. Basically it's
like they're product aware uh or offer
aware, but we need to be have people who
are like more pain aware. So some hooks
that you want to experiment with are
going to be more pain driven.
>> Mhm.
>> So like are you bored? You don't know
what to do? Like you would know the
pains better than me. But like
>> inside and out.
>> Those are the pains that I would use as
my hooks more than some of these bottom
funnel. It's good to have offers and
talk about the bootcamp and all that
stuff. Like that's that's here, right?
That's going to be here. But if we want
them to scale, you're going to you'll
probably need to have some hooks that
are up here.
>> Yeah, okay.
>> And that will allow you to really open
up the the targeting.
>> I love that.
>> Okay. Now,
this is the cadence side. And so let's
call this is number three, which is the
hooks. All right? And also number four
is the decision, which is that I want to
challenge you to be willing to do a $100
check.
All right? That's my challenge.
>> Honestly, I feel like there's no
challenge cuz I'll just do it now. I
never go into my launch capping my total
ad spend if the ads are performing as I
want them to. And I just think I haven't
been anywhere near enough aware of this
before preparing for, you know. So now I
know my numbers more than before.
>> In the first month you get it back.
No big deal.
>> And I'll stop kicking myself every time
>> Yes.
>> for launch versus.
>> She's killing it already. I think she's
an amazing human being. I spoke to her
and she's she's amazing, period.
>> [music]
>> I have two two things.
Cuz you already have a model that works.
The last thing I want to do is break
everything. All right?
But you got this last time. What was the
painful offer specifically that you
added?
>> Oh, when we spoke before, you'd said
>> Sell the annual.
>> Yeah, yeah. And really don't sell
monthly at all.
>> So then what percentage of people took?
And it was 10?
>> from being um normally it's like a 5 to
15% or 10% normally take annual. And
then previously when I switched to
pitching really annual, it went to 30%.
That's why we had that 91.
>> Okay. So you got 30%.
Um
okay. I think that on your
launch checkout page, let's say you've
got your
you've got your annual and you've got
your monthly, right? These are the two
options.
I I think that there should be a bump
here.
Like after they select
>> There is a bump right now, but it's only
to my $47 course, which is a little bit
like you like this stuff here some more.
>> Mhm. How does that do?
>> That's just 30%.
>> It's pretty good. To the sticker paper
is one that I would put. Because if they
need this to do the thing
>> Yeah.
>> then it's like we might as well just
>> Give it to them.
>> Give it to them, right? They want the
exact stuff.
>> Yeah. This is my This is my whole kit.
So, just let's call this the bundle,
right?
If we can make this the physical bundle
>> Yeah.
>> Do you might be able to get get away
with like $99 or something like this.
>> Mhm.
>> And it's going to super high margin,
right? Big. Right. No, no. But, in the
US though, it'll be much slower, right?
>> it's way better. So, for sure.
>> Yeah. Which if you wanted to be wild
with it, you just put this in here.
>> Mhm.
>> So, if you buy the monthly and so then
what happens is we can actually make
this a bit of a false offer. Meaning
>> decoy.
>> Kind of. So, it's like if we make this
$149 and we'll Let's just
Let's just go crazy, all right? Let's
say this is $149 for my full physical
bundle.
>> Mhm.
>> You say, "But hey guys, if you're going
to If you do the annual, I'll throw the
$149 in."
>> I like that. Loads. Yeah, yeah.
>> Yeah. This is what I'm saying with the I
want a physical product premium for
annual cuz we Your Your LTVs are already
around 300, so I don't I was thinking
cuz if it was much lower, I'd say,
"Okay, maybe we can lower the annual and
then we'd get more takers." But, if
that's not the case and we know that
they have to have this
>> Yeah.
>> in order to do the thing.
>> Definitely.
>> So, if they're like, "Well, I'm going to
have to buy this either way
I might as well get all the bonuses and
get the stuff I need to do the thing."
>> committing to annual. It's like them
making a decision to commit to the hobby
for a year.
>> Yeah, cuz you're on constant assume you
like $10. Maybe plus another $10 in
shipping. Who cares? But, that might all
of a sudden take you to 50% here.
And that'd be big, right?
>> Wonderful.
>> Yes. Okay. So, the big decision that I
have is this.
This would be a a higher risk test, but
this is like
one that I would strongly consider.
>> I'm not risking this.
>> Okay. Which is I would rather just not
mention the monthly at all, sell the
annual, put the offer in there.
>> Yeah.
>> And then after the launch is over, when
you close your cart, then run everyone
else to your monthly that doesn't have
the bonuses. Cuz then you can do a mock
up, okay?
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz you'll still get plenty on that, but
this will because like if you're doing
you're doing a full five-day thing, you
can sell a $300 ticket.
And so people are just taking the
cheaper one because you're offering the
cheaper one.
>> Right.
>> My goal here was how can I get that spin
number? How do you feel comfortable? If
you knew all of a sudden your AOV is
$300, so maybe conversion cuts in half,
but you are at a $300 sale.
>> level of confidence here.
>> Yeah. Cuz now you're now if you're at
150 in the first 30 days, you're like,
"I'm fine. I can spend more of that
money."
>> Spending, yeah. Cool.
>> So I had a wild So I I two wild ideas,
right? Wild idea number one is, let's
just sell the annual, put this in there,
and I think if we add this to that
and make that the full offer,
>> Yeah.
>> I think that'll do well.
>> Mhm.
>> The second wild idea that I had,
um
And again, this is wild.
This is wild.
Is that we position
the boot camp
as
a seven-day trial
of your $27 membership.
>> That goes even without you saying
anymore, it goes so well cuz the whole
point of it is supposed to be like a
teaser, a taster of this is what you get
if you're a member.
>> Yeah.
Because then you automatically convert
it 100% of your traffic instead of 20 to
>> So they're signing up for the continuity
and they have to cancel that.
>> Yeah, and and then you're running a a
seven-day or a five-day, whatever that
you know, whatever you want, but then
your whole thing is pushing the annual.
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> So you have 100% conversion.
And then you push everybody to annual.
>> Yeah.
>> That's my that's my wild test.
>> I I really like it. I guess my
I'm worried that that I'm going to get
to the the challenge ends after a couple
of weeks then the 30 days end and I've
and people
leave.
>> Well, then what but this is such a good
onboarding, too.
Like the 7-day challenge is also just
onboarding for all the members.
>> Yeah.
I love I love a test.
>> Could arguably test both
>> Mhm.
>> at the same time, which I'm not always
the biggest fan of. Cuz if we look at
the math, right? Let's just do the math.
So, let's say you've got 100 people who
who buy your thing, right?
>> I can.
>> Yeah, they buy the book, yeah, right?
Where you know that we're we're going to
have 22 of them who are going to have a
lifetime merch profit of 300, right?
So, we have whatever that is, 6,600
that's coming in from these people,
right? Now, on the front end, it's
costing you $3,700,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, you get these people.
>> Right, yeah.
>> And this is the issue from a cash
perspective, correct? That's the
problem.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, you said that you get $91
uh
>> Now, yeah.
>> Yeah, that $91 is only on the buyers,
correct?
>> Mhm.
>> It's not on these people.
>> No.
>> Okay, that's
>> on the 22%.
>> That's the issue.
>> Yeah.
>> So, this is the real problem.
>> Yeah, so where this where where it gets
more interesting is like let's say that
you spend $3,700 to get 100 and uh you
make
$3,500
>> Yeah.
>> whatever, right?
>> Which could be yeah.
>> So, then that would mean you have $200
to acquire 22 customers is what the net
net actually works out to.
>> Yeah.
>> So, that helps you to calculate is
crazy.
>> It's not how I built my list for free.
>> Yeah, you spent $200 to make 6,600.
That's great.
So, the idea with the trial would be
if we had those same 100 people, but
let's say the trial conversion at the
end was it'll probably be closer to like
55%. Like especially if you do like a a
5-day thing like this. And all of a
sudden you're at 55 people and they have
the same $300 LTV. Now, that doesn't
include the fact that we're going to get
annuals, but even if no one bought
annual, and we just had the 300, now
we're at, you know, 15 or 16 five.
And so, we would you'd actually make up
for
the money that you didn't make on the
front. Now, obviously, we still have
upsells. We should still do that. But,
I'm saying even if you had no upsells
>> Yes.
>> and you just had this
>> Yeah.
>> you would make more cuz here all in
you're at, you know, 90, whatever that
is, you know, 11 or 10,000
uh is what you're making here versus 16.
So, you get like a 50, 60% lift.
>> Mhm. Mhm.
>> So, that would be like that would be the
play if it was trial.
>> Mhm.
>> But, I think you can go trial
and then
upsell tools.
Right? Upsell the stuff they're going to
need for the challenge.
>> Mhm.
>> Right? And then you'll still be able to
get some cash
uh from all those people. And you could
make it a $1 trial.
So, you want So, you have a working card
or whatever. I would not introduce this.
I would do this first.
>> Yeah, I think so, too. Okay, cool.
>> Do this first.
>> know for a challenge, but that feels
>> Yeah.
>> That's very manageable.
>> Yeah, so this [music] is I'll say test
B.
>> I see that. I
>> And this is test A.
>> have so much confidence that doing this
alone is going to hugely change the
outcome of the event in terms of members
and [music] profit. And then I feel like
that's like the explode step.
>> Yes, and you can say this, you only get
all the tools if you buy at the annual
during the event.
>> Right. Yeah.
>> Cuz it costs a lot of money and I got to
ship it and I got to figure all this
stuff out. So, I can only do it for
people now.
>> Yeah, I really like that.
>> I feel good about it.
>> I feel good about it, too.
So, when Alex talked to me about the
trial, offering a trial and having that
be a way to really help my members get a
really good experience during a launch,
that has really helped me think about
the way I've been looking at bringing
new members in in a completely different
way that that I'd never considered. I've
definitely considered doing a free trial
before, but not during a launch in that
way. So, that blew my mind and it def As
Alex said, it's a bigger, bolder move,
but one that I'm really excited to take.
>> It was a simple plan, a simple plan.
This is the spin cadence we follow. I
know it works very well.
We're going to do it way more creative
this next round.
>> Here we are.
>> Right? You're going to create more
organic as well, which is going to feed
the list, too.
We're going to have more pain-based
hooks, so we can go a little bit up
funnel.
>> Yeah.
>> We're going to increase our spending
capacity from an account perspective.
>> Right. Yeah.
>> And the test that we're going to run on
the next one is this one.
>> Yeah.
>> And if that works, [music] then all the
game is going to be is how do I make 800
ads
and spend $100,000 on my next launch.
>> Done.
>> [music]
>> All right, let's see where we're at with
the scaling revenue.
Okay. Yes, thank you. Thank you. Thank
you. So,
how many employees do you have right
now? Like two?
>> Yeah. One is my husband.
>> [laughter]
>> Let's see here.
Your revenue's a little bit higher than
your head count would suggest, so you're
probably more on this side
>> Yeah.
>> uh than you are here.
>> Mhm.
>> And so,
what we're doing is if we're walking
through this,
we're going annual, we're adding the
stuff to price to a better person. We're
making all this extra content to make
better free stuff, and also V2 of this
test is actually just running the trial
>> Yeah.
>> as the the front-end offer. We're making
more creative to boost the volume.
>> Mhm.
A little bit more.
>> Yeah. Also, as a side note, I don't know
if you're already doing this, but I
would make sure that you optimize your
campaigns around purchases if you're not
already
>> I always do. Just in case.
>> to.
>> Yeah. And then, the one thing that I
didn't see on your numbers, but I would
like to get to is just EPCs.
>> Mhm.
>> So, earnings per click. And I think
you'll sleep better knowing that you are
doing fine.
>> That's it. You just giving me this is
enough, and so the more I know, the the
better I'll be with that. Yeah.
>> One thing that I did I did miss is um
I think we should consider
when you're making these ads, you should
get hook variations.
>> Yes.
>> I would experiment with different
call-outs for avatars. So, like in in
lead book, we talked about call-outs.
>> I've done that only to only a limited
way, literally separating mothers and
grandmothers, but I haven't really done
a great
>> I would go underneath of I would go more
sub-specific, but like the game is now a
game of 100 ponds and no oceans. Like
you're you're draining 100 ponds of
audiences
>> Right.
>> to get your scale more than trying to
advertise to the oceans.
>> To the world.
>> Right. Like you're running two ads and
trying to convert you're trying to
convert everyone with the same
messaging.
>> It's it's true.
>> Right. And so if you want to get the
scale, you have to go down, which is
counterintuitive.
>> No, I like that.
>> Cool.
>> That's easily done, too.
>> All right.
Rock and roll.
>> I know that despite anyone getting a
scale or a fail, there'll be nothing
stopping the people that I met today.
I'm so inspired by them. As much as we
know that we are contestants and
competitors, and I'm certainly not
glossing over the fact that this is a
competition at the end of the day, we
really came here to just represent
ourselves and be the best version of
ourselves that we could be, and [music]
I think that everyone shared that goal.
>> So this is scale or fail.
To be clear, I think that
all of this will literally just get you
more of what's already working.
There's very few universes where I think
that you
adding the physical product premium and
only presenting the annual offer doesn't
generate more revenue up front. And
we've de-risked this test by being able
to just run it as a split test with the
exact same price point. $10, $10 on
both. That way the ads can be the same.
One just includes a trial, one doesn't.
Everything else in the funnel will still
be the same.
So
the question is
do I want to spend a year working with
you to scale this?
Or
do I think there's something that's
going to get in the way that's going to
prevent us from scaling?
So the verdict is
you will be scaling with me. All right.
So, you're moving on to the next thing.
All right. This is a very simple plan.
I just want you to not be afraid to
spend more. You can't be afraid. And
you've gone through enough stuff.
There's no reason you should be afraid.
Right? It's like you know how to make
money.
>> Yeah.
>> You can always go back to what you did
before.
But, this has the potential
to 5x or 10x the business.
>> Right.
>> And I think
I think this will work.
>> Thank you.
>> All right, we'll rock and roll.
>> Thanks, everyone.
Alex just told me that I am a scale and
I'm so excited. I'm so happy. I have so
much faith in my business, in my ability
to implement everything that he said,
and it just feels like so much has just
opened up for me. So, it was a
combination of him validating some of
the things that I was worried about, and
he gave me a really good solution for
them that I hadn't been able to reach by
myself. Um, and then a few other tests
that I can do, too, but there was
nothing that I'm not really excited to
try. And I can't wait to see how things
go.
>> I felt no resistance on any of the the
things he was recommending. And also,
the last thing that I told her to do,
she partially did and it doubled her
average cart value. And so,
I am pretty confident that both of these
things
will dramatically increase her cart
value. And in the business that she's
in, she's in a media arbitrage business,
which is fundamentally can you buy
clicks for less than you can make on
them because it's a very scalable
business. And so, like honestly, once
just the math gets right, she can just
do this. And from a product perspective,
she had 5% churn, which is really good.
>> Hearing from Alex that there was so much
potential to scale has not only
validated what my hopes were and what a
lot of the data was pointing [music] to.
To me, it's simple. If I follow the
process that I've been given and I trust
in that [music] and I do the things I
say I'm going to do, then the success is
inevitable.
The next 90 days are going to be
incredible.
>> The business I felt like it could scale.
It was a good product, very wholesome,
and I didn't think [music] she would be
afraid. And since she'd been marketing
for 10 years, she had the technical
chops to do all of these things. So,
there's really nothing that was really
stopping her besides the decision and
the strategy, which she just got both
and she made the other. So, this was
scale or fail. See you next time.
>> Okay, let's do an update. One thing that
Alex really encouraged me to do was go
much bigger on ads in terms of
creatives, angles, testing, volume, and
I've been using one of Alex's playbooks
to um come up with ads and a way to test
them in a really strategic way. I'm
already seeing with early stages of
promotion everything going in the right
direction, exactly as Alex said it
would. What a shocker. So, yeah, that's
my update. Let's see what happens.
>> Next time on Scale or Fail.
>> My name is Tina Sue, and I help parents
[music] of children with autism, ADHD,
and speech delay.
>> You have a responsibility to the
business, and the business has a
responsibility to the customers. But,
your responsibility is to make sure the
business survives and grows. So, if
you're going to do that, you need to
make it like five times as expensive.
>> Oh.
>> So, it's like think like 8,000, 8,000,
10,000 is what it would be if I wanted
to have. So, I have to decide whether
you scale or fail.
>> I can execute.
>> No.
And so, I'm very torn on this one of
whether or not you can draw the line.